um what do I think I would be doing when
I grew up it's funny I think I always
thought that I would wind up in comedy
somehow I guess I kind of envisioned
myself being like a bill murray or
somebody who was a my hero but I didn't
ever actively pursue comedy as a career
it just sort of like happened I never
really thought that I while I always
fantasized about it as a kid I just for
some reason it never seemed like
something that I should actually really
pursue so so I think I envisioned myself
being as much like Bill Murray as I
could and having kids and having a cabin
up in the woods somewhere and so one of
those things has happened so far that's
good
I think he was such a specific kind of
comedy that was sarcastic and confident
but also not cold and soulless you know
like not just doing comedy on the
surface level there was something really
endearing about him and you got the
sense that even though he made cynical
remarks that he was a kind of flawed and
normal guy as well you know I think he
just really sort of the standard bearer
for this tone of comedy that a lot of
people from my generation grew up with
you know Steve Martin was in there as
well Chevy Chase in those days we're all
I don't know if they're big influences
but I guess I haven't done a lot of
reflecting on whom I comedic influences
actually have been growing up with you
know two younger brothers and sarcastic
parents probably was the biggest
influence of any you know I don't think
anybody can really make me laugh you
know like my little brother Matt or my
dad or my brother Nick so I think that
had a lot to do with it